how did you come up with the idea uh for
standard cognition what was the
inspiration
yeah i mean i think everybody hates
lines yeah and everyone
hates self-checkout even more than that
yeah uh
that's that's a pretty easy concept you
could go back 50 years and say what
would you like to improve about your
shopping experience well i don't want to
wait 10 minutes to get out of here
so i think the idea is pretty easy it's
just that now is kind of the zeitgeist
that the technology and you know the
state of machine learning is getting to
a point where
you can feasibly remove all of that you
know
sweat like let's just get out of the
store let's let's make this really
seamless
and so how does it work exactly i know
you have to have an
app what do you do you do well you get
the app and then you just show up at the
store and you walk in and out with
some shampoo yeah and the goal is really
just to completely remove the notion of
transacting
from stores you know if you think about
what uber and lyft have brought to the
world of taxiing basically is
you just you don't think about
transacting anymore you pull out the app
and you call the car
but then you're done when you get to
your destination you just open the door
and you leave you don't even think that
you're paying
but we want to bring that same
experience to stores you walk into a
store you grab what you want you walk
out
and that's it you are transacting but
you're not thinking about it it just
happens automatically so removing
friction equals more joy for customers
absolutely absolutely so assuming we
walked in here and we had the app
would the app know we're in the location
or do we have to check in explicitly how
does it work yeah so right now you do
need to check in that's the one the one
piece of engagement we still need
but we're working on removing that as
well yeah i mean you know my location
right if i give you my location
information shouldn't you know i'm in
this place why do i need to check in
yeah so we do know you're in the store
but there's a tricky problem the
check-in problem is what we call it
actually where
if there's 20 people in the store we
know that all of 20 people are
in this geo-gated location okay but we
need to be able to associate your
payment information
with a particular person in our tracking
system ah
and we've walked in but if three of us
walked in
how do you know which person took the
soap versus the drink
versus the mug exactly so we have a
collection of cameras overhead our
system's completely
vision based it's all cameras got it
it's anonymously tracking all the
shoppers in the store
but we don't do any facial recognition
so there's no way for us to be able to
recognize you and say hey this is joe
schmo and that's intentional we've
designed the system with that
that privacy people care about that so
some people care some people don't care
but i don't care like if i walk into a
store i'm already like
any bodega i would walk into in brooklyn
had closed circuit television
yeah why do people care so cctv and a
facial recognition system that we're
going to deploy across the world are
slightly
slightly different and it depends on the
geography in terms of the actual
laws around this uh as well as the
culture around it so the us is sort of
somewhere
in between the extremes europe is going
to be on one further extreme of right
being much more privacy preserving
and then there's countries and
jurisdictions that are further on the
even other side of the extreme where
you actually probably have to do facial
recognition okay so i come in i check in
that i'm in the store
you know i'm in the store but based on
me hitting the check-in button
you know the exact moment i'm in the
store i'm ready to shop exactly so
do you know my location as well based on
like the wi-fi signal so the camera can
pinpoint me in the store so the cameras
alone no wi-fi actually are doing
precise visual tracking down to the
centimeter of wherever shopper is
which is actually a pretty cool
application on its own forget about
checking out we know where every shopper
is
down to the centimeter throughout their
entire shopping trip got it so
things that we want to roll out in the
future would include in store
positioning how do you know
two people come in and they press the
button let's say it's a big store and
it's busy
two people press the button at the same
second or two seconds how would it know
who's who
so we do a visual sync on the phone ah
so what happens is
two or three or four people are trying
to check in each one of them get a
distinct
color we display that on the screen the
cameras are watching got it camera says
person seven's got a blue screen
and my user checking system that says
they sent blue to user seven
or to joe rather now we can make that
association